bonjour alexis fait à la faune jour vous
les élites et en martinique
vous êtes l'un des quatre candidats de
combat ouvrier en lice en martinique et
vous vous êtes principalement dans le
nord de l'île merci d'être avec nous
dans ce cas mieux vaut d'abord de la
présidentielle française alexiane combat
ouvrier supporte nathalie arthaud de
lutte ouvrière elle n'a pas encore ses
signatures et hier sur une télévision
d'information continue elle
reconnaissait les difficultés de faire
campagne vous ressentez des mêmes
difficultés ici en martinique une
difficulté c'est un non seulement c'est
les travailleurs clés au sein des
difficultés en martinique
vous savez la bourgeoisie de
représentants la bourgeoisie n'a pas
problème pour eux d'avoir les signatures
puisque tous les élus tous les hommes
politiques actuels sont alors service
alors nathalie arthaud à la différence
des candidats de gauche de droite et
d'extrême droite
elle ne prétend pas défendre les
intérêts de la france et des français
comme ne peut-on pas non plus défendre
les intérêts de la martinique des
martiniquais quand il ya deux france
qu'à la france des riches et la france
des ex pratique
alors donc elle dit que dans ces
élections là c'est l'occasion pour les
travailleurs de dire ce qu'ils pensent
la situation actuelle est de dire à vous
faire entendre quand des travailleurs
pas pourquoi ça ne décolle pas sachant
que lorsqu'on défend les travailleurs on
défend tous les travailleurs nous sommes
tous des travailleurs
ça devrait fédérer davantage mais les
toits verts nous écoutent ils nous
écoutent
il ya de nombreuses grèves qui se sont
passées qui se passe en tunique
on a vu la gueule de fontaine didier où
le travail obtenu satisfaction aux
revendications et la gueule des hôpitaux
et la grève des municipaux et à la grève
de la poste il ya moins j'avais la grève
chronopost ou les travailleurs exiger de
meilleures conditions de travail
en 2009 outre les salariés lorsqu'on va
dans le bureau de vote sont neutres les
travers nous écoute
il est qu ils se font entendre le
terrain des luttes entendre leur camp
contre l'exploitation patronales et
gouvernementales
maintenant à ces élections c'est de
faire un geste politique en votant pour
le camp
alors quand il faut faire ce geste
politique sociale je voudrais canaux
lire pendant toute l'émission le fait
qu'ils vont venir j'ai mes idées à moi
et je j'ai douté j'ai pris mes notes
donc
donc je dis que c'est il faut que les
travailleurs justement profitent ces
élections pour 10 qui se méfie des
hommes politiques de doigts ils veulent
ils ont massivement pour eux ces hommes
politiques c'est ses représentants de la
bourgeoisie comme vous dites
or vous vous êtes quand même sur un
terrain où tout le monde devrait être
fédérer sur sur vos idées la libération
du cadre de vie
mais je répète que travailleurs nous
écoutent ils nous écoutent avec
maintenant il faut qu'il fasse à travers
la lutte qu'ils ont mené qu'il mène
alors qu'ils transforment dcc 777 et
goûtent comment j'ai justement tic
comment le faire comment transformer
justement cela qu'on geste politique
mais pourquoi vous n'y arrivez pas on
leur dit que dans ces élections
élections il faut revendiquer cette
norme de droit c'est-à-dire et poser des
salaires que les salaires soient
correspond au coût de la vie de
l'échelle mobile des salaires
il faut qu'ils étaient redis ces
licenciements parce qu'il ya des
entreprises qui font du profit et la
suprise paix et les plans de
suppressions d'emplois
il faut répartir le travail entre tous
sans perte de salaire
il faut imposer la transparence des
entreprises passées d'autres pays font
du profit les travaux ne savent pas
contrôler ce qu'ils font ils les traces
il est super combat n'est pas facile à
sylvanès pas facile mais seulement vous
avez en face de vous des hommes
politiques de droite de gauche qui
n'arrête pas nos sombres de mentir aux
travailleurs mais qui le racontent
n'importe quoi
vous avez par exemple ont menti ni queue
yan monplaisir les devants il est de bon
copain de fillon fillon vous avez ce qui
se passe actuellement
voilà le monde bourgeois dans lequel
nous vivons que tes enfants
neuf cent mille euros que sa femme a
gagné un travail ne pourra jamais divisé
par le nombre d'années de galère
corruption la corruption et kehl à
l'autre mais arrive en tête
non c'est ça que j'ai entendu à la radio
ce matin ben voyons voilà le monde bouge
dans lequel vivent les travailleurs qui
nous écoutent
on leur dit qu'il faut que leur lutte
qu'il mène qui transforme seuls 8 en
conscience politique et donc on
s'adresse à eux pour leur dire qu'ils
ont des revendications avancées et
notamment en ce qui concerne les
salaires et des admissibles travailleurs
touchent 1100 euros par mois aux 1400
nous disons qu'un salaire minimum de la
tête ne soit pas inférieure à 1800 euros
net par mois
et c'est possible mais ça mal
travailleurs s'ils le disent qu'ils le
disent avec nous qu'ils votent qui
disent le disent avec nous que le
refrain de travail il faut légiférer
pour cela donc il faut se faire entendre
durant la législative
comment vous vous le ferez dans le nord
alors que semblent se semble arriver ce
duel annoncé entre bruno restera 0 le
sortant et yan monplaisir que vous venez
de nous ne savait peut-être marcellin
nadeau en embuscade comment vous vous
glisserez à travers à ces trois
personnalités
alors avant je jouais dit que le
non-inscrit science fiction où les
traditions de luttes ont été fortes
il ya eu les 16 de basse pointe et il ya
eu aussi la gamme 74 on a parlé ce matin
qui a comme en irak sac avec 43,3 en
quête travailleurs se sont fait
massacrer par des capitalistes béquilles
alors il est suivi une grève ap donc ça
aussi il faut le savoir il ya les
travailleurs de tout est beau qui se
battent qui ne se laisse pas faire un
bain pour ce qui concerne les duels
entre mon plaisir à 0 d'un côté un homme
de droite que yan monplaisir qui
substitue substitue un soutien fillon et
qui fillon qui les mène une politique
offert des cadeaux au patronat ce même
fillon qui disent que le smic il faut
pas l'augmenter que sa femme elle touche
lui 5000 euros par mois
sadi trois mille tweets et 3000 trois
fois plus que le smic bon et dans le
côté en a zéro qui allie à vals valls
qui lui qui a cassé les doigts les
travailleurs pour satisfaire aux
appétits des patronats donc il y avait
alors un boulevard royal pour vous ça
dit que je voyage je ne sais pas si on
appelle comme ça mais je peux vous dire
que voilà ces hommes politiques qui qui
approuve de côté valls et hollande n'y a
pas que y'a pas que ce mondial mais ya
aussi la chimie qui soutient valls aussi
que c'est qui personne semble être très
ancré dans le pays martinique et ses
hommes politiques la voilà ces deux
hommes politiques font le deuil qu'ils
ont c'est ce gouvernement qui agaçait de
40 milliards au patronat d'un côté un
qui le mine amic le copain de fillon et
qui dit ce qu'il a dit gyan à ces thèmes
qu'il est la famille de la ctm avec
marie-jeanne ils sont de la même famille
patrons qui exploitent les centaines de
travailleurs et à montplaisir et puis
l'autre côté elle est à 0 qui a soutiré
vaste d'ailleurs il a dit de la déclaré
dimanche soir que qui va le voir en
france
ah ben voilà donc les travailleurs c'est
souvent là c'est cela qui appelle la
population à voter pour eux pourquoi
mettre en place des personnes politiques
pour continuer à les exploiter continuer
à mener des politiques d'austérité
contre une alors on dit aux travailleurs
de se méfier de ces gens là parce qu'il
demande aux gens de revoter pour des
gens et leur demandent à la population
d'en brasser les mains du monstre qu'il
ait cliqué lesquels et qu'il est votre
dryland tendrait la main du juste du bon
celui qui qui à la vérité la vérité cela
booste robert qu'elle ait tous les jours
il lui tous les jours il est tous les
jours y défendent leurs droits à tous
les jours et cette politique cette lutte
qu'il mène
je répète qu'il faut que la transforme
en conscience politique
il faut que s'expriment par ce faux pas
que leur boussole restent dans leur
porsche faut pas qu'ils perdent leurs
repères
il faut qu'ils manifestent aussi leur
mécontentement il faut que ne fasse pas
confiance à des hommes politiques qu'ils
s'agisse de marie-jeanne de letchis
me 2 à 0 de montplaisir ce sont des
serviteurs ils sont et soutiennent le
gouvernement soutiennent ils ne
remettent pas en cause sa société
capitaliste ils soutiennent cette
société là merci d'avoir été ce matin
avec nous à l'ex du fia le rappelle que
vous êtes l'un des quatre candidats de
combat ouvrier que vous êtes en lice
dans le nord de l'île merci d'avoir été
avec nous dans son crédit
bonne journée
[Musique]